mr. ken Langone Chairman and Managing
Director of inva met Associates speaking
to us from New York why are you
supporting Ross Perot Brian I think he
offers us the best hope of getting
America going again and getting America
back to the basic values that made this
country what it is
there's a lot here and and the best of
all of the people and I think Russ will
offer inspired leadership and really get
the American people back to the things
that matter that that's the reason I'm
going to UM I'm supporting loss what do
you think of the first two debates that
we've been watching well I was very
excited by mr. Perot performance on
Sunday night in st. Louis and I can only
tell you that what the American people
saw on Sunday was Ross Perot he didn't
rehearse for that in fact on Sunday
morning he had his grandchildren on
horseback and he was showing them how to
use a bow and arrow he came up to st.
Louis he was he was high he was really
ready to go and of course it was obvious
how well he did Sunday night and they
after Sunday night he was he was pleased
with how it went he was pleased that he
had a chance to answer some questions
I think it's regrettable that the format
was such that it was only really two
minutes at a time but still I think the
American people got a pretty good
glimpse at Ross Perot on the fire
Jim Stockdale is a wonderful leader and
I think the mistake the American people
could make by drawing a conclusion on
his debate was that just because he
wasn't as polished as either quail or or
Gore don't be confused by the man's
inner strength and the man's values and
the man's capacity to lead I might
mention here that that Jim got the medal
it was received the Medal of Honor for a
very interesting reason after the
prisons were released Jim who was the
highest ranking officer in that camp
these prisoners came forth and testified
that it was his leadership and his
inspiration and his example that gave
them the strength and courage to endure
the horrible horrible suffering and
brutal treatment they received at the
hands of the Communists and many of them
said that if he had not been there they
probably would have died that had given
up the will to live he himself was
subjected to the most indescribable
torture possible from one year one to
another human
he's a brilliant man he's a decent man
and he loves America and I really think
that that he is the issue you had Gore
and you had Quayle who have gone to
debating school for the last 16 years at
the taxpayers expense and America has
got a choice to make in my opinion we
either go with the people who really see
where America ought to be and are
willing to lead us there accepting the
fact that sometimes they're gonna make
very politically unwise decisions or we
can go with these people which is what
we've done for many years in the past
who tell us what we want to hear and
promise to give us what we want and
that's not the answer because in the
final analysis someday somehow we all
have to pay for these promises and we're
seeing this right now in America today
so those are my those are my analysis of
the debates and the people we're very
excited about the debates one more thing
about Jim he may have noticed the other
night that he was moving around the
podium that was because Jim has constant
pain in that lane he was offered a stool
to sit on and he said if the other guy
they use on his stool offset on a silver
defense Danny I'm standing and so that
tells you something about the man's
commitment to letting the world know
what he wants he's a wonderful man his
wife Sybil she single-handedly made the
plight of the prisoners the issue that
ultimately led to our government getting
involved in the prisoner issue without
her for sure many of those men would
have been tortured to death and died it
wouldn't be home today so she deserves a
lot of credit to mr. lorn going our
subject this morning his business and
our three guests more or less reflect
the candidates that we have for
president when did you first get into
business my father-in-law got me an
interview with an insurance company here
in New York I'm a New York boy and in
their investment department he was in
the investment business and times
weren't so robust 1957 they were okay
but they weren't like we knew in the 80s
and so forth but I
up getting a job as a trainee in the
investment department of a major
insurance company and that led me to
Wall Street and from Wall Street
everything else happened
I became Ross Perot's investment banker
that's how I met him
it's 24 years ago I started in the Med
in 1974 because I was very interested in
the medical field and I wanted to dwell
on that and we did what is in the Med
Internet is an investment banking firm
member of the New York Stock Exchange
who when we founded its primary focus
was to invest in the medical field in
the Med we've since veered off into a
variety of other directions for example
one of the companies we co-founded is a
company called the Home Depot so we're
we're a very small firm that specializes
that has a very focused and narrow
client base and the best I can describe
to you is what we are and when did you
is this the first time you ever been in
politics oh yeah and I think probably my
love for lost you know decides to do
more later on this is not my field I I
think I'm - I've spoken and I think most
people that I know like me are the same
way we we we like to get things done and
that so that I recognize as a
self-serving statement but truly we
really like to see achieve and we like
to were driven by achievement and we're
all frustrated terribly frustrated by
what we see they call a gridlock I call
it paralysis in Washington you know what
most of us have here that that have been
fortunate to have been blessed by all
this country has to offer
feel two ways about it we feel number
one tell us the rules and we'll play by
them
and for the most part we'll probably
succeed but the more important thing is
we all realize from whence we came and
we say my god if things keep going the
way they are the kids that come after us
are going to not have that opportunity
to live the American dream so I'm in
this thing not for political purposes
I'm in us because I truly believe Ross
is the answer to get America going again
you look around ya
don't listen to what I say just go out
your doors this morning and we'll talk
to people and and
around and see what's going on and
you'll see yourself and by the way
American is not coming apart at the
seams America is a powerful country it's
a strong country it's a wonderful
country all we're saying is let's not be
so complacent let's not take it so for
granted because it may not always be
that way what I think that's yes sir
what is your view if Bill Clinton is
elected president what will happen to
the business community I wish I was
smart enough to answer that question I
don't think it's an issue of Bill
Clinton to George Bush because I think
the more I look at politics the more
there isn't a heck of a lot of
difference between Democrats and
Republicans and conservatives and
liberals I think that it's a matter of
the American people looking to their
leaders to tell them what's right for
them not what's right for the leaders to
get reelected or to get elected you know
they say that political risk what
political risk really means is telling
the people the truth knowing that in
telling them the truth they might not
vote for you Ross Perot said the most
profound thing of all on Sunday night
when he said if you hate don't vote for
me
and just like or stands on uncertain if
the American people aren't willing to
recognize that we aren't going to come
to grips with the deficit and the debt
and all the other to counter that goes
on down there
unless we take some pain then they
really shouldn't vote for us because
we're going to end up being no different
than the rest of them so my problem
isn't was Clinton my problem isn't with
Bush my problem is with getting the
American people to realistically look at
what they should expect from government
and what they should expect from their
leaders mr. lion I just think that
Clinton and Bush both are back in the
same mold which is you know promised
them everything even though you know you
can't deliver did you if you don't mind
me asking did you vote for George Bush
in 88
oh no no no I vote for George Bush I was
one of George Bush's most vocal
advocates and I think the Republican
Party people will agree that I was one
of the
more prolific fundraisers what a battery
what about Ronald Reagan I didn't work
for Reagan but I was a staunch Reagan
support and I think Ronald Reagan for
example was in the right direction I
think for example Ronald Reagan made the
point he said look I'm not gonna let you
tax these people and spending this is
where the deficit came from they
continued to spend the money he wanted
to give the money back to the people the
wisest spenders of money are the people
who earned the money so I must tell you
uh this nonsense that Ronald Reagan
Reagan led us to where we are I don't
agree with that I think this I think
that that a George Bush stayed the
course better than he had I think he
might have a better shot shot at
reelection today but I think he wavered
I think for example right after Desert
Storm
had he demanded the line-item veto and I
was told us by a couple of very
prominent senators Republican senators
that he had he demanded the line-item
veto that he probably would have gotten
his popularity was so I and if he didn't
want to get it from Congress take your
next bill it comes across his desk and
strike out something that's unattractive
to him you know who disagrees with and
make it a constitutional issue give it
to the Supreme Court that would have
been political courage but he didn't do
it so I think the choice here is us
versus the status quo and the status quo
is both Democrats and Republicans ken
Langone was born in Roslyn Heights New
York he has a master's in business
administration from New York University
and an undergraduate degree from buck
now let's take a call from Chino
California go ahead please yes good
morning
I'd like to make a comment and ask a
question I don't have a problem with
Admiral Stockdale I think he is an
admirable man and I would be proud to
have him as a leader I have more of a
problem with mr. Perot I wouldn't feel
comfortable with him and what I've heard
about this temporary kind of scene about
September I'm like my business question
is I'm curious as to whether or not the
attacks that George Bush is not
on his house in J bunk port and what he
does by putting an address that he lives
in Texas in the hotel that does not have
rooms for rent but is closed down if I
did something like that
where it gets a lot for me thanks yeah
ma'am I'm I wish I could answer that
question I'm not an authority on tax law
or the laws of Texas and I don't want to
take a shot at the president but if it's
the way you describe it
I think that's regrettable what do you
think of this story running about mr.
Perot paying less than the average
percentage of his income on taxes
because he's got so much money tied up
in municipal bonds can he explain that
one sure mr. Perot with his net worth
has a variety of different investments
and I'm sure municipal bonds are a part
of that portfolio and the law simply
states as an incentive to loan to local
communities in the states that and the
purpose of that law was to keep the
borrowing cost down for the school
districts and the municipalities and so
forth so mr. Perot said that straight
away simply loaned money effectively
loaned money or bought securities of
those authorities and the tax exempt but
I will promise you this ma'am mr. Perot
probably in the last 15 years was at
least one of the 10 of 15 highest tax
payers in America Ross Perot has paid
tens of millions and hundreds of
millions of dollars in taxes and I might
add all that money that mr. Perot made
and paid taxes on he did it it's not
inherited wealth it's not something that
was done anyway in the process of
accumulating that wealth I might also
point out that ETS today has 70,000 plus
employees Ross Perot by anybody's
measure is a job creator and I can
promise you that any analysis of his tax
returns at all would indicate two things
he complied with both the letter and the
spirit of the law and he did it straight
away I might also point
something else the world is full of
people who have benefited by Ross
Perot's charity the Perot family are
very very charitable people so what he
also pays in taxes is additionally all
make augmented by us charitable
activities Rochester Minnesota go ahead
please yes good morning I'd like to
thank you for season and wonderful
programs I would like to comment that
after watching the debate the other
evening I've always voted Republican and
I I'll be the first to a minute I'm not
proud of that choice right now but at
the time I thought that was the best
move I personally reached a saturation
point
with the the name-calling and the
undignified behavior they're pulling
away from the issues which I feel I have
to commend Admiral Stockdale the other
evening if he was the only one who truly
focused on the the issues and stated
exactly what he wanted to say without
added rhetoric and forth like the other
candidates
he also was the only one the other night
who wasn't called a liar call right how
are you going to vote definitely rostro
that this is the most politically aware
I've ever been in my life and I we have
to start looking at the issues choosing
our priorities and I think focusing
America back to be a country that is
strong and morally correct mr. Langan
let me ask you about the election at
this point what chance is to give Ross
Perot of actually winning I think it's
in the hands of the gods by the way I
you know there's a there's a doom that
that the administration people are
sending out resumes and looking for jobs
I think both major candidates have
support bases a mile wide and an inch
thick I don't I don't believe their
bases are that strong I think a lot
people are voting for Bush feel they
can't vote for Clinton and a lot of
people are voting for Clinton feel they
can't vote for Bush the yearly the UH
approval rating it was a comment at the
Times in New York Times this morning is
still very high for both of them so I
think that that much is going to revolve
around the remaining debates and I urge
everybody watch Ross Perot's aired on
Saturday night when he talks about his
recommendations and the things he would
do to come to grips with the problems
confronting America today I think this
is a wide-open race I saw in the Wall
Street Journal yesterday morning that
there was talk that he was as much as
20% which for a guy that just came into
the race three weeks ago
two weeks ago I should say that's a
pretty strong move I think the American
people are starting to realize that
school's out and I wouldn't be surprised
in fact I fully expect that Ross will
win this election and I wouldn't be
involved we're not doing this to stir
things up we're doing it to win let me
ask you a quick question I'm gonna ask
you just keep it 15 seconds because
we've got a call waiting it what's the
first thing you would do from a business
standpoint if you were in the White
House making the decisions or you were
advising Ross Perot I would immediately
begin the process of looking at every
single significant government
expenditure for example let me give you
one right here in New York City New York
City has 62 million square feet of space
vacant today and the federal government
is beginning the process of building an
800,000 square foot building now you
want to talk about something ludicrous
here's overcapacity and here's a very
small fractional need of that over
capacity the US government today could
probably drive the best bargain 11 make
for space and yet they're going to
proceed ahead for political reasons
whether they want to create jobs or
whether they want to accommodate a
senatorial request whatever I don't know
the reason but it's the first thing we
would do is to say stop the presses
right now and let's see what we can do
to stop spending immediately with the
least dislocation that's one
hold on there because I want to grab
this call from Rochester New York go
ahead Rochester you're on the air caller
I have a question about the national
debt a lot of people say worried about
it Macross is saying a lot of people say
don't worry about it
I know Ross had 1.3 billion in Treasury
bonds so forth how much of the national
debt is held by private citizens thanks
how much of it is held by foreign
investors thanks ma'am I don't know and
so much of that is hard to track because
many government bonds of bearer bonds ie
well they are as a matter of fact they
think that you know unless people report
what they have there's no way to track
them I think it's safe to say that
certainly in the 80s we were
accommodated as a nation by substantial
foreign buying of our securities
principally Asian and European buyers
rates were high the American government
is accepted as a as the top credit in
the world so it was money good I don't
think there's any way to really I'm sure
there are statistical numbers around I
don't have them I think most of them are
probably banks institutions and foreign
holders how big is your company in
vivent yeah by what measurement either
yeah either Katherine umber of people
that work for you well we only have we
have 12 people and we have capital of
approximately 50 million dollars San
Diego go ahead please good morning sir
good morning Mike Mike my question to
the gentleman is how is Ross Perot going
to get the moribund House and Senate to
work with him because to me that seems
to be almost an impossible task very
easy that's that's gonna be the easiest
job of law if Ross Perot wins this
election you just think about yourself
as a congressman or senator the American
people will have sent a very loud and
clear message that they bypass the
political parties and that this is their
man this is Ross's platform by the way I
will be a servant of the people I will
work for you so they will have a
franchise that's entirely their own and
I would think it would behoove any
senator or congressman if he wants to
get real like
that's what it's all about with these
guys to get the message loud and clear
I'll give you for instance you get a
good number of people to call up any of
these senatorial office or any
congressional office on an issue they
listen if the American people go to what
the what these parties call this extreme
of electing an independent candidate we
will ascent a very strong message to
Congress that the party's over and let's
get the job done and by the way because
mr. Perot is beholding tonight a party
where he doesn't get the cooperation
that the people want that his bosses
want
I know Ross Perot will go public with it
looking at the Richmond times-dispatch
special section on tonight's Richmond
debate there you can see the arena
almost ready we go to Yadin Pennsylvania
go ahead please yes I have a question
regarding mr. Burrowes plan specifically
the price per gallon increase on
gasoline and what I'm curious though is
how that would affect the already
displaced workers low income and the
unemployed who are searching for work
and you know maybe unemployed for say
the next year or so won't that make the
situation worse for the working class as
opposed to better thanks well yes look
somebody always gets hurt when we pay
more taxes and we've got to focus on
that we've got it we've got to consider
other thing that people are both parties
are trying to say that Ross is going to
come in with this program and lay it
flat down no matter who it hurts that's
gonna be it that's not the way it's
going to happen they will be
considerable although I must tell you
fast
work done one of the possibilities would
be to have some form of a subsidy for
people who are out of work and who need
gas to travel around to look for work
but look at the other side of that with
all that money that comes in will be
dedicated to rebuilding our roads or
hospitals or our bridges or our mass
transit facilities those are all job
creators so if the tax one
brought in and spent on programs and
projects like that you create jobs with
the money over the short term I don't
have the answer man but I might my my
visceral feeling is that what you
probably do is to maybe has some form of
a of a of a subsidy or some form of his
exemption on minimum number of gallons
used like we had rationing him I don't
want to get into a bureaucratic thing
here but there's a lot of possibilities
to reduce this thing on those people who
can't afford it but overall the American
people have gotten a free ride in terms
of fuel costs in fact when you talk
about conservation if you wanted a
really impact conservation back then
leave when we have the when we had the
shortages in the 70s all you had to do
was to put a gas tax on but you see
there was a case of politics they
wouldn't do it even though it was the
right thing for America they wouldn't do
it because they were afraid they'd lose
votes by doing it and you got to tell
the American people you got to say look
here's the problem here's a solution
and hence we recommend now somebody is
going to be unhappy with that solution
and if enough people are unhappy and
vote against you you got to stick to
your conscience you got to stick to what
you know is right and that may not be
the politically wise thing to do but
that's the way it's got to be a couple
more minutes for Ken I'm gone we go to
Memphis Tennessee you're off yeah I'd
like to ask you a business question but
let me ask you this first mr. pearl who
was the representative of I believe Bush
at the disarmament talks Richard you
alone yeah he was on c-span here within
the last 30 days and he said this is
what mr. Perot said the other night that
there's a greater set threat on a
nuclear holocaust now than before Russia
disarmed for this reason that these
countries like Iraq Libya these
terrorist countries are getting these
nuclear weapons and some of it was due
to the fact that Bush coddled Iraq and
gave all these weapons and information
through the agricultural department here
a while back and they passed on all this
information to Libya and Syria and so
forth and so on and I like your comment
on that
secondly my business question is I
believe that some of this problem has
come from the reagan-bush over-expansion
the SNL fraud and the HUD fraud and so
forth during the 80s and now we got to
pay for it now in the 90s I'd like you
to comment on the other one first this
one second thank you the SNL mess is not
a bush of Reagan I'm not gonna defend
George Bush or Ronald Reagan here the
SNL mess is a mess of the entire
government the SNL deregulation was
jointly Congress and the executive
branch they did and now to make a
political issue is wrong here is an
example of where a lack of business
experience a lack of of just good common
sense on the part of all politicians
allow that mess to occur the-- the HUD
mess obviously that was the
administration I don't know how profound
it was I can tell you this that as a
result of the SNL problem it's about 100
billion dollars a year right now so I
think that's probably the big issue your
question about nuclear holocaust or the
threat of it I don't know that I you
know there's so much you read about of
accusations of who did what to who who
who coddled who who gave what equipment
to walk through the agricultural
department you're a better man to me if
you can keep and it's one of the
problems the American people have we
don't know what the hell these guys are
doing down there
Burlingame California thanks I don't
know Pat Buchanan at all I will only
tell you this that as an American I was
very disappointed at the whole tenor of
the Republican convention I don't think
there's any room certainly in this
country and in this world
or polarization as Ross said none of us
are going to leave America so we better
figure how to get along with each other
I think that that specifically about
Buchanan I know he's a passionate
believer in in the things that mattered
in him and I respect him for that I
don't agree with everything he believes
in he is certainly an intelligent man I
think he probably means well but I think
I didn't agree with his speech at the
Republican convention I didn't agree
with a tone that it said and I regret
that I regret that for all Americans
including Pat Buchanan because we all
lose with polarization mr.liang gone we
only have 15 seconds if mr. Perot does
not win this election do you think he'll
stick around in politics I don't know
about politics but he'll stick around as
an American and be involved as I said I
don't know whether the loss would do
this again but I can tell you right now
that Ross Perot would certainly be
actively involved in helping the
American people sort through the mess
ken Langone Chairman and Managing
Director of in lament associates based
in New York and support of Ross Perot
thanks for joining us thank you very
much and have a nice day we'll be back
with more discussion on the 1992 race in
a few minutes